[Musik]
berichten des tages heute mit niki sie
rieten ihnen allen einen schönen guten
abend wir sortieren die nachrichtenlage
wieder für sie natürlich auch sportlich
mit kristin auto so ist es geplant unser
team hier im überblick
der erste tag im amt kanzler scholz
bespricht mit den ländern die korona
anlage
außenministerin berbalk setzt in paris
und brüssel zeichnen
impfungen für kinder
die stiko empfiehlt vor erkrankte und
kinder mit kontakt zu risiko patienten
impfen zu lassen
licht und schatten bei den bayern die
münchner ziehen ins
champions-league-achtelfinale
müssen aber wegen corona folgen weiter
auf josua kimmig verzichten
es war heute der erste tag im neuen
leben von angela merkel und gleichzeitig
der offizielle erste tag der neuen
bundesregierung was das für den neuen
kanzler scholz east dazu gleich mehr
zuvor der blick auf den ersten
arbeitstag der neuen grünen
außenministerin berbalk die frisch
vereidigte zum antrittsbesuch direkt
nach paris und brüssel reiste und sich
dort gleich zu krisen dieser welt
positionierte mehr von anne gellinek
schon die anreise der neuen deutschen
außenministerin nach brüssel soll eine
botschaft seien sie und ihre gesamte
delegation kommen mit dem zug aus paris
annalena baerbock will den
internationalen teil der klimapolitik
als außenministerin selbst verhandeln
das ist neu und findet in brüssel zu
fall des terminkalenders auch noch zeit
für ein kurzes gespräch mit dem
amerikanischen sonderbeauftragten für
klimaschutz john kerry am ersten tag im
amt spricht berbalk in paris und brüssel
von verlässlichkeit die neue ampel
regierung wolle europäischer sein als
die alte und streitlustiger
menschenrechtsfragen und werte sollen ab
jetzt bei der außenpolitik im zentrum
stehen auch mit blick auf china am
morgen in paris bleibt berbalk bei der
frage nach einem möglichen deutschen
boykott der olympischen winterspiele in
peking erst mal vorsichtig wir werden
sowohl gemeinsam in der neuen
bundesregierung
darüber entscheiden wie wir weiter damit
umgehen und das aber in einklang mit
unseren europäischen
freunden
auch neu ist dass sich eine grüne
außenministerin über einen termin beim
nato-generalsekretär freut der russische
truppenaufmarsch an der grenze zur
ukraine beunruhigt europa baerbock mit
einer deutlichen warnung an wladimir
putin russland würde einen hohen
politischen und vor allem
wirtschaftlichen preis für eine erneute
verletzung der ukrainischen
staatlichkeit zahlen gleichzeitig müsse
man auf dialog mit russland setzen zum
beispiel im nato russland rat fordert
berbalk morgen folgt der vielleicht
schwierigste teil der europäischen
antrittsreise die neue außenministerin
wird in polen erwartet
fragen wir nach bei anne gellinek in
brüssel an erstmal ging es ja ums
kennenlernen aber lässt sich dann schon
absehen ob der bock deutschlands
außenpolitische tonlage geändert und da
vielleicht auch konflikte aufgemacht
werden
annalena baerbock war heute an ihrem
ersten europäischen arbeitstag sehr
vorsichtig und deutlich bemüht nichts
zusagen was irgendwie falsch verstanden
werden könnte aber trotzdem hat sie ja
veränderungen der außenpolitischen
tonlage angekündigt unter der
überschrift härte und dialog und das
kann tatsächlich zu spannungen führen zu
aller erst zu hause in der berliner
ampelkoalition und das besonders bei
zwei themen erstens die chinapolitik
annalena baerbock an sich sehr wohl
vorstellen hier eine härtere gangart
einzuschlagen während der bundeskanzler
olaf scholz wohl eher die
außenwirtschaftspolitik seiner
vorgängerin angela merkel fortsetzen
möchte und 2 beim thema russland und der
pipeline nord stream hier kann annalena
baerbock sich ebenfalls vorstellen diese
pipeline erst gar nicht in betrieb zu
nehmen während große teile der spd
diesen stopp mit großer skepsis
betrachten also die frage einer neuen
außenpolitik wird sich zunächst an dem
streit entzünden wer sie eigentlich
macht der bundeskanzler olaf scholz oder
die außenministerin annalena baerbock
dankeschön anne gellinek nach brüssel
zurück nach deutschland wo sich auch die
anderen neuen köpfe der bundesregierung
an die arbeit machten für bundeskanzler
scholz der zur stunde noch mit den
ministerpräsidenten debattiert fing der
tag ziemlich schillernd an und zwar mit
us-präsident beiden die beiden haben
sich heute gesehen wenn auch nur
virtuell
ines trams zeigt uns dass ein demokratie
gipfel der erste termin für den neuen
bundeskanzler olaf scholz auf
internationaler bühne
kontaktaufnahme mit us präsident joe
biden wenn auch nur via bildschirm
amtsübergabe im umweltministerium auch
bei bildung und forschung
tag eins der neuen regierung immer noch
geprägt von staffel übergaben auch im
finanzministerium der alte minister
jetzt kanzler doch darauf nach corona
wieder konsequenter zu sparen das
bedeutet natürlich dass das solide
wirtschaften nicht vergessen werden darf
denn wenn diese krise irgendwann war
hoffentlich vorbei ist müssen wir
bedenken die nächste könnte kommen der
neue weiß er wird nicht alle forderungen
als finanzminister erfüllen können heute
will er optimistisch klingen wir haben
projekte definiert für die nächsten vier
jahre
und deshalb möchte ich als hier jetzt
wirken der minister
dieses ministerium verstehen als ein
ermöglichung ministerium die neue
familienministerin macht klar jede
gesetzesvorlage soll künftig nicht nur
einem klima sondern auch einem
gleichstellungs jack unterzogen werden
das bedeutet jede vorlage die ins
kabinett kommt muss geprüft werden ob
sie gleichstellungs und frauen
politischen fragen rechnung trägt im
bundestag nehmen die neuen minister und
der kanzler ab heute nun auf der
regierungsbank platz die grüne katrin
göring eckardt wird als bundestagsvize
präsidentin gewählt sonst fast schon
business as usual
ein bekanntes thema wird zur stunde auch
im kanzleramt beraten corona erstmalig
lädt scholz als kanzler die länderchefs
zur ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
also noch läuft die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz theo koll
in berlin es geht also um corona aber
auch um den hass im netz was können sie
uns sagen
ja die themenpalette war diesmal
deutlich breiter als sonst bei corona
dreht es sich im wesentlichen um die
impfpflicht morgen soll ja im
infektionsschutzgesetz festgelegt werden
dass zum 15 märz eine einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht gilt also für
beschäftigte in kliniken pflegeheimen
arztpraxen und so weiter olaf scholz
hatte ursprünglich die allgemeine
impfpflicht schon für februar
angekündigt und das zweite große thema
der runde ist die immer massiver werden
der hetze gegen korona maßnahmen die
ministerpräsidenten fordern heute
einhellig dass kommunikationsdienste wie
beispielsweise telegramm über die sich
dann gewaltbereite gruppen organisieren
stärker reguliert werden müssen das zdf
magazin frontal hatte ja vor wenigen
tagen über mordpläne gegen den
sächsischen ministerpräsidenten
berichtet das scheint jetzt politische
konsequenzen zu haben vielen dank nach
berlin theo koll wir bleiben bei corona
tausende eltern sind verunsichert und
haben auf die empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission
gewartet und zwar sehnsüchtig jetzt ist
sie da kommt aber mit einschränkung eine
krone impfung für 5 bis 11 jährige wird
nur für kinder mit vorerkrankungen und
kontakt zu risikopatienten empfohlen
eine generelle pflicht für kinder wollte
die stiko aktuell aber nicht geben
dominic müser müllers l mit mehr
features und till sind willige vitus ist
gesund till hat eine vorerkrankung ein
nervenleiden heute sollen beide geimpft
werden der eine sollte der andere kann
kinderärztin volker brinkmann von der
uni klinik bochum ist froh dass sie nun
die rückendeckung der stiko hat
erleichtert unsere arbeit sehr wenn wir
eine offizielle stiko empfehlung haben
weil wir dann die sicherheit haben dass
das auch gut geprüft und empfohlen ist
und auch rechtlich eben ganz ganz gut
abgesichert und das ist etwas was uns
das impfen erleichtert das natürlich
aber auch den eltern die entscheidung
noch mal erleichtert sich dafür zu
entscheiden die stiko empfiehlt eine kuh
wird impfung zunächst nur für kinder mit
vorerkrankungen oder für kinder in deren
umfeld besonders gefährdete personen
lieben kinder ohne vorerkrankung können
auch geimpft werden nach entsprechender
ärztliche aufklärung so die stiko im
moment will sie aber noch nicht allen
kindern uneingeschränkt eine impfung
empfehlen da das
nutzen-risiko-verhältnis noch nicht ganz
klar sei
sobald es mehr daten gibt will die stiko
neu bewerten vitus und hilf mutter ist
froh dass ihre kinder nun geimpft sind
eins mit empfehlung 1 ohne
sorge bereitete war nach wie vor auch
omikron vor einer infektion mit der
korona variante schützt laut experten
nur eine dritte impfung und tatsächlich
boomt das boostern ihre auffrischimpfung
haben gestern fast eine million menschen
bekommen so viele wie noch nie
dreifach geimpft sind mittlerweile 16,6
millionen menschen also 20 prozent der
bevölkerung fortschritte also beim
impfen während sich zu omikron aber noch
viele fragen stellen christoph distel
wieviel omikron fälle gibt es aktuell in
deutschland ein paar hundert schätzen
virologen 28 davon sind offiziell
bestätigt die zahl dürfte aber rasant
steigen wie ansteckend ist omikron sehr
wahrscheinlich sehr über 30 mutationen
am bei der infektion so wichtigen
stachel machen es dem virus offenbar
besonders leicht sich zu verbreiten
wie gefährlich ist eine infektion mit
omikron auf diese kernfrage antworten
forscher unterschiedlich in den usa eher
zuversichtlich
bei drei viertel unserer omikron fälle
handelt es sich um geimpfte aber immer
verläuft die krankheit mild
deutsche forscher sind etwas
vorsichtiger ein trend zeichnet sich
aber ab da sieht es nicht so aus als ob
das jetzt deutlicher krank macht oder so
inwieweit schützt eine booster impfung
jetzt auch vor omikron virologen sagen
boostern weg noch einmal die gesamte
immunabwehr des körpers dürfte also
zumindest schwere verläufe verhindern
auch bei neuen varianten
sollte man bei der auffrischung den
impfstoff wechseln das sogenannte kreuz
boost dann kann man machen aber besser
nicht empfiehlt die whu obwohl einiges
dafür spricht und zwar wenn ich dann
einen m arena im stoff für die dritte
impfung nehme da funktioniert sowohl bei
montech sehr gut als auch vor allem
moderner sehr gut das haben studien
gezeigt so oder so die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde ema red ab heute
dazu schnell nach zu boostern also nicht
erst nach sechs sondern schon nach drei
monaten
ja noch aber bestimmt data die pandemie
und den zahlen drückt sich das dann wie
folgt aus das robert koch institut
meldet 70 1611 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden
2598 weniger als vor einer woche die
sieben tage incidents sinkt leicht auf 4
122,3 innerhalb eines tages sterben
465 menschen und viele stellen sich
tatsächlich die frage führt co wird 19
wirklich zu mehr todesfällen als üblich
ja und zwar ziemlich deutlich sagt das
statistische bundesamt stefan schlösser
berichtet
mehr als 900 85.000 menschen sind im
vergangenen jahr in deutschland
gestorben rund 50.000 hatten kobe 19
statt ist ischen bundesamts belegen dass
die virus erkrankung zu einer massiven
über sterblichkeit geführt hat wenn sie
den zeitraum märz 2020 also beginn der
pandemie neben bis februar 21 haben wir
eine über sterblichkeit von 7,5 prozent
einen maler verlauf altersbedingte
sterblichkeit hätten wir einen zunahmen
von zwei prozent der vergleich der
todesfall zahlen mit den vorjahren zeigt
dass insbesondere in den vier wellen der
pandemie die zahl der verstorbenen
deutlich angestiegen ist doch sind die
menschen tatsächlich an oder lediglich
mit dem virus gestorben rund 70 prozent
der korona toten waren über 80 jahre alt
viele hatten vorerkrankungen
rechtsmediziner und pathologen erfassen
ihre obduktionsergebnisse in einem
nationalen register das führt zu einem
eindeutigen befund sie sterben ancona in
85 prozent der fälle mindestens ist
eindeutig die virusinfektion die
todesursache in den anderen fällen sind
beispielsweise unfälle oder auch akuter
herz todesfälle dann der eigentliche
mechanismus des todes aber weit
überwiegend eindeutig die infektion die
behauptung die menschen wären auch ohne
corona in kürze gestorben ist also nicht
haltbar
jetzt zum innenministertreffen in
brüssel hauptthema die dramatische
situation der flüchtlinge die belarus
richtung polen schickt zum ersten mal
dabei auch die neue
bundesinnenministerium nancy faeser die
das vorgehen lukaschenko schon im
vorfeld ist skandalös und
menschenverachtend nannte polens
regierung hat entlang der gesamten
grenze zu petrus eine drei kilometer
breite sperrzone errichtet dort
kontrollieren armee und grenzschutz das
gebiet bei eisigen temperaturen harren
tausende migranten weiter aus und hoffen
auf hilfe anne brühl
gerade haben helfer ihnen eine
rettungsdecke gehüllt um ihn vor der
kälte zu schützen den mann aus syrien
aber interessiert nur eins
zurück nach belarus nein
polnische helfer sind besorgt über das
was in der grenzregion passiert menschen
die sich verstecken weil sich fürchten
von polnischen sicherheitskräften zurück
nach belarus geschickt zu werden diese
woche wurde ein toter unweit der grenze
entdeckt wir nutzen alle möglichkeiten
die wir haben aber wir wissen dass wir
nicht jeden erreichen können im osten
polens herrschen strenge
minustemperaturen
das verschärft die situation
trotzdem hält polen an der sperrzone
fest eine praxis die auch die neue
deutsche innenminister bei einem treffen
in brüssel kritisiert
für mich ist es aber auch wichtig dass
rechtliche standards
eingehalten werden an der grenze
deswegen wäre ein einsatz von frontex
dort gut und was ebenso wichtig für mich
ist ist das auch die hilfsorganisation
jederzeit zugang zu den menschen
bekommen in nicaragua wo unweit der
grenze wünschen sie sich taten kein
mensch sagt uns der vize-bürgermeister
sollte mehr in den wäldern sterben
müssen uns nicht hier geht es nicht nur
um die polnische regierung sondern um
die gesamte eu die schmeckt die in
keiner weise reagiert wir werden von
vertretern verschiedener eu
institutionen besucht da was passiert
einfach
so sammeln sie weiter warme kleidung und
lebensmittel es ist das einzige was sie
tun können
der wochenlange machtkampf bei vw ist
beendet zumindest vorerst der
aufsichtsrat hat entschieden herbert
diess bleibt vorstandsvorsitzender
allerdings wird seine macht
eingeschränkt und die führung des
konzerts umgebaut dies muss das wichtige
china-geschäft an vw markenchef
brandstätter abgegeben vor allem wegen
seiner pläne massenhaft stellen
abzubauen war dies konzern intern in die
kritik geraten
und es passt jetzt wie weil wir
sportlich nämlich in wolfsburg bleiben
einige sorgen für florian coesfeld und
den vfl ist der traum vom
internationalen geschäft vorerst
geplatzt 13 gegen den osc lille als
tabellenletzter raus aus der champions
league und für die europa league nicht
qualifiziert obenauf dagegen der fc
bayern münchen der als einziger
deutscher verein in der königsklasse
überwintern zum zweiten mal in der
vereinsgeschichte zieht der fc bayern
mit makelloser bilanz ins champions
league achtelfinale ein thomas müller
leitet den sie gegen barcelona mit
seinem fünfzigsten champions league tor
ein knapp hinter der linie aber drin
lieber seine erhöht mit einem wuchtigen
schuss auf 2 0 und jamal musealer macht
in der 62 minute den sieg über den
glanzlosen fc barcelona klar ist jetzt
keine große verwunderung dass sie heute
gegen uns verloren haben so das war
schon klar das ziel von uns und auch von
mir persönlich im achtelfinale drohen
den bayern härtere brocken als
gruppen-erster könnten sie auch paris
arrangement oder den fc chelsea treffen
mitte februar dann aber wohl auch wieder
mit joseph emich nach seiner tweed 19
erkrankung verkündet er corinna negativ
zu sein jedoch fällt er wegen
anhaltenden lungenprobleme auch für die
restlichen drei spiele des jahres aus
und
alles zum sechsten spieltag der
champions league finden sie in der zdf-
heute- app bund auf zdf heute.de die
deutschen handballerinnen bleiben bei
der wm in spanien in der erfolgsspur das
viertelfinale rückt näher nach dem
vierten sieg im vierten spiel und der
dominanten vorstellung gegen die krassen
aussenseiterinnen aus dem kongo
für die frau der republik kongo ist es
die handball wm premiere das routinierte
deutsche team hat wenig mühe johanna
stockschläger trifft zum 29 18 entstand
ein favoriten sich mit schönheitsfehlern
die schwache chancenverwertung fällt
unangenehm auf trotzdem glaube ich sind
wir nicht zufrieden mit unserer
vorstellung wir wollten deutlich
konzentrierter staaten und es spiele
auch über 60 minuten durchziehen einen
sieg am freitag gegen südkorea und
deutschland steht erstmals seit 2013
wieder im wm viertelfinale ja das wäre
ja das wetter ist es nicht so richtig
dass kristin das hält heute nacht
einzelne schneeschauer straßenglätte
bereit und mehr erfahren sie gleich von
western terli marietta slomka empfängt
sie später zum heute journal um 21.45
das war es von uns danke fürs zuschauen
machen sie sich noch einen schönen abend
und gerne bis morgen um 7
[Musik]
ein stück oder amte und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das eine schnelle
gebiete im osten zieht allmählich ab
aber das nächste nähert sich schon von
westen mit diesem tief hier und vor
allem morgen tagesverlauf gibt es schnee
oberhalb von 400 metern darunter wird er
in sein und von westen her nähert sich
warmluft die uns dann am sonntag
erreicht und mit gefrierendem regen für
glatte straßen vor allem im osten
deutschlands dann sorgen wird aber erst
mal der blick in die nacht da gibt es
einige schauer mit regen und schnee und
dort wo es regen und schnee gibt kann es
teilweise auch überfrierende nässe geben
und dementsprechend glatte straßen im
osten gibt es noch etwas schnee der
lässt allmählich nach im süden klart es
auf die temperaturen gehen dort bis auf
minus zehn grad runter über
schneeflächen kann es noch kälter werden
sich im osten mit minus 3 grad aber auch
im südwest mit minus 1 bis minus 2 +3 im
nordwesten deutschlands morgen also im
tagesverlauf der schnee der allmählich
reinzieht oberhalb von 400 metern
allerdings sonst ist es regen im osten
gibt es auch sonnenschein mit höchsten
temperaturen von minus 1 grad an den
alpen zb und 4 grad ganz im westen die
kommenden tage ja am samstag im süden
etwas regen und schnee sonst trocken
minus 15 grad danach kommt regen auf und
dieser regen sorgt für glatte straßen am
sonntag ein schöner